يمتد الاستيطان على الاراضي وعلى مر
السنوات ملاحقا الفلسطينيه حتى في المساحه
القليله المتبقيه له بعد النكبه
الفلسطينيه اي في الضفه الغربيه التي لا
تتعدى مساحتها اثني عشر في المئه من مساحه
فلسطين التاريخيه
لكن المستوطنات لا تقام على اراد فلسطينيه
عامه تسلبها سلطات الاحتلال فحسب بل ايضا
على اراد ذات ملكيه خاصه كانت تقام
المستوطنه عند حدود بيتك وحديقتك وغرفت
نومك تماما كما هو حال هذا البيت
الفلسطيني
على قطعه ارض مساحتها 100 دونهم
في هذا البيت وعاش مع والده المرحوم مراحل
استيلاء المستوطنين على اربع من من ارضهم
يعني السجن اسرائيلي اااه فش فش في بيتنا
احنا طبعا شوفوا كيف المنطقه المستوطنه
قديش قريب علينا احنا صفينا يعني اقرب
مسافه بيننا وبينهم يعني فش مجال بيني
وبين المستوطنين عرض المستوطنون مبالغه
وامتيازات كثيره لكن العائله رفضت ان تترك
بيتها
تستذكر ام سمير سنواتها الاولى في المنزل
قبل ان يحجب المستوطنون الهواء عنها كما
تقولوا
علينا بوابه سكر
بطلنا نشوف الهواء زينه
واعت اتهم ولا يخفي الوالد قلقه الدائم
على اطفاله نطلع
علينا
اوراقه ثبوتيه تؤكد ملكيتها للارض وقد
يكون ذلك ما حال دون تهجير العائله بعد
المعارك القضائيه التي خاضتها يقول سعادات
انه سيورث ابنائه كل ماورثه هو عن والده
البيت
ومعاني الصمود فيه
نسوان سمراء الجزيره من قريه بيت جزاه
شمال غربي القدس المحتله